hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 15 video all about
fixin just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen it yet the DC giveaway is
still going on this week - that'll stay
open until I do my legends of tomorrow
video all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on this
video entertainment earth where I get
those flash rings from is running low so
it's just gonna be a normal $20 Amazon
gift card so if you guys missed it
before arrow and flash started their new
seasons at the end of last year they
premiered this really short vixen
animated series it was like six episodes
that all amounted to about 30 minutes of
content CW has this digital platform
called CW c-calm where they have some of
their programming that they don't
necessarily air on TV they wanted to try
out a DC character that they weren't
ready to make a full series for so the
Vixen show was kind of a test meant to
set her character up and they'd always
intended to either do the character in
live-action or a user in one of the
other shows so as of right now there is
no live-action vixen series on the books
they they haven't said anything about
making one of those what they'll
probably end up doing is a user again
during arrow season 5 next year in
legends of tomorrow season 2 it would be
awesome if she joined the cast
permanently for legends of tomorrow
just like Constantine really hoped that
Constantine who got a big shout out in
this episode comes back for legends of
tomorrow season 2 close do top 5 WTF and
I'll do Easter eggs as we go along
most of them vixx and related couple
mister terrific ones in there too number
Felicity is starting to walk again the
biochip that mr. terrific mate is
working the only thing I didn't like
about this is that it miraculously just
like turned on at the end of the episode
I think it would have done that
eventually anyway but they wanted this
dramatic effect where she walks away
from all of her like look this isn't
working I can't do this anymore
so you know from chip not working at the
beginning of the episode to it
completely fixing her at the end and I
understand what they were trying to do
with it so it's okay and I felt like it
was too much too soon I would have
rather just seen her wheel out like you
know put the ring down on the table and
then wheel away the Easter Egg is that
they mentioned mr. terrific came in to
get physical therapy when he was trained
for the Olympics in the comics he was a
bronze medal to Kathleen so number 4 WTF
the death of olicity some of you are
cheering because you hate olicity some
of you are really upset Marc Guggenheim
posted this picture of a wedding later
this season he said it's not a trick
he's not playing shenanigans so it's
point they do get back together there is
a wedding whether or not that sticks
remains to be seen
I feel like personally superheroes
aren't allowed to have lasting
successful relationships you can be hot
and heavy with people you can have
relationships they just they can't be
like normal people's relationships you
don't get to have a normal life you can
have children but if you're gonna be a
superhero
they're gonna have a messed up childhood
that will drive them and become their
origin story when they become a
superhero someday or super villain as
the case may be
so if arrow is gonna be a real comic
book show then they can get married they
can totally get married it just it can't
stick for forever
number three WTF we actually find some
magic the Baron writer is digging for
but whatever the explanation is the
spirit that protects this place inhabits
the body or assumes the form of dead
Conklin but Constantine's tattoo that he
got earlier this season protects him in
the spirit totally lets him into the
club also like the big Constantine shout
out in this episode can we get his help
no he's in Hell actually physically in
Hell number two WTF enter vixen we
finally get to see her in the flesh and
her totem is badass I love that my
family gave me my freedom in this totem
that makes me a total badass just a
great way to walk out at the end of the
episode and she can fly it's so awesome
there are so many reasons why we need
more vixen in the arrowverse she's a
really good character to begin with from
the comics she already has a really
awesome backstory and there's done a
good job of developing her and I like
the way they addressed her backstory
from that animated series vixen and I
had an animated adventure earlier this
year and I think she would add some of
the spectacle that is missing from arrow
that flash has because most people on
arrow don't have powers number 1 WTF
though that end scene with team arrow
versus damian darhk-- vixen shows you
what her powers are capable of she
literally goes apeshit to smash the
totem in the bike stunts were amazing
thea like bending over backwards to fire
the arrow she's actually getting pretty
badass but vixen flying and crashing
through the roof is probably my favorite
stunt from the episode and it's not
really WTF but I do have to high-five
the riders for actually doing a good job
of addressing the reality of what was
going on with Oliver him keeping secrets
in it being the right thing to do but
also addressing the consequences of all
of his actions like even Laurel
is still stinging a little because she
hasn't gone out with all of her for a
long time she is emotionally let him go
but she's still like oh my god he had a
kid with the woman he cheated on me with
this sucks I feel like that's 100%
honesty most women would probably try to
jab his eyes out in high fives to Diggle
for being an awesome dad I actually had
forgotten his daughter's name was Sarah
they named baby girl Diggle after Sarah
Metta WTF though most of you have
noticed the arrow flash in probably
legends of tomorrow are going on break
for a couple weeks there won't be new
episodes till the end of March so I'll
totally be doing bonus videos for
everything while they're off the air if
you have any special requests just let
me know in the comments below
but Easter eggs let's see I think I
already mentioned most of the stuff
about vixen and Constantine being in
hell vixens backstory I explained a lot
of that during the vixen videos that I
made earlier this year so I'll put a
link for that playlist in the
description what about the grave though
and the way things were left between
Merlyn and Thea I'm thinking more and
more than when Oliver says I have to
kill him he's talking about Merlyn not
about damian darhk-- because from the
way Merlyn was talking to Thea it
sounded like he would do anything like
literally anything if he thought it
would help save Thea's life and they
didn't really address it but when
Merlin's talking about big picture he's
probably talking about this hive plan
Thea you're not thinking about the big
picture he just he didn't save that high
fat is terrible plan and you're all
gonna die so let me know in the comments
after this episode do you think that
Merlyn is the one that Oliver's talking
about when he has to kill someone and
who do you think is in the grave now but
I felt like that end tag with him
leaving the message for his son like
you'll see this when you're 18 your mom
isn't gonna tell me where she's taking
you means that they're off somewhere
else and they're fine and we won't see
them again tomorrow is gonna be bad
freaking ass though legends of tomorrow
gonna do Connor Hawke in a future
version of Deathstroke but if you are
confused as to why all of her son
William is not Connor Hawke they just
they explained that they wanted it to be
a separate thing like they wanted to be
able to do Connor Hawke on the TV show
and the Sun at the same time and the
reason that he's an african-american in
these pictures is because he's an
african-american character in the new 52
Connor Hawke of the comics is the son of
Oliver Queen and his african-american
girlfriend it's just that the TV show
decided to not make them Oliver Sun
that's the only thing they've changed
so why he goes wait for that video to
post tomorrow you can click here for my
top 20 Batman kills there's this big
talk about Batman V Superman getting an
r-rated cut he's killed a whole bunch of
people in the comics and you can click
here for my flash King shark zoom video
from last night thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow